[Musique]
dans le cadre de la semaine bleue le
président du conseil départemental
cyrille melchior est allé ce mercredi 10
octobre à la rencontre des gramounes du
cirque de mafate
c'est sur le stade près de l'école de
marla qui était organisée une journée
intergénérationnelle dédiée à la
préservation du patrimoine culturel et à
la sensibilisation sur l'éducation la
prévention et la santé
le département accompagne cette belle
action réalisée ici à marla dans mafate
par les deux associations de familles de
malades en lien avec noria pas et la
structure pourrait bien être ce soir le
département les accompagne tout
simplement parce que nous avons en
charge les personnes âgées notamment
celles et ceux qui sont les plus en
difficulté et je tiens à dire que nous
nous inscrivons résolument dans le cadre
d'un plan pour les seniors parce que
vous savez qu'à la réunion il ya de plus
en plus de gramounes et il s'agit de les
accompagner d'accompagner leur famille
de façon à ce que ces gramoune soit bien
considérer bénéficie de la solidarité
départementale
une vingtaine de professionnels étaient
présents sur les stands proposant des
ateliers allant des gestes de premiers
secours au diagnostic de vision en
passant par le bilan d'autonomie ou
encore la prévention des chutes
l'occasion pour tous les mafatais
d'échanger de s'informer et d'exprimer
ses attentes
cette année c'est une journée
intergénérationnelle du patrimoine
patrimoine social et culturel comme avec
donc la venue de tous les mafatais du
cirque de mafate
après on a aussi de la prévention santé
qui est là avec nous pour sensibiliser
les gramounes échelle aussi tous les
participants nous avons aussi à des
ateliers
de théâtre on a de la musique c'est sûr
y'a un gros de la chanter donc voilà
c'est pas mettre en valeur tous les
patrimoines social et culturel du mans
fait quand on voit ici j'ai un enfant
quand on voit ici les parents et les
grands parents
et bien c'est simple lien
intergénérationnel qui fait la force de
la réunion qui fait la force de notre
vivre ensemble
mais c'est quoi ça le département
accompagné on accompagne en particulier
nous ramons à toutes les gramounes parce
qu'il faut de la solidarité en faveur
des drames
[Musique]